Yeah. I don't even know
why it's that coordinated
with all kinds of people, you know.
put the chain into a soup,
and then it goes to a kitchen, and --
If you have the chain, you run out.
Hi, my name is Octave
Durham, nickname Oky.
I did more than 10,000 burglaries.
I've robbed everything you can imagine.
My name is Arthur Brand.
I'm from the Netherlands.
I'm an art detective.
I'm responsible for recovering
250 million [pounds] of stolen art.
We now work together in
trying to prevent art heists.
We are going to look at diamond heists
from Hollywood movies,
and we're go to watch
how realistic they are.
If you do this in real life inside,
everybody would --
would have been dead, I guess.
No, but look at the mechanism as well.
I mean, it doesn't look like that.
I did this a couple of times,
and they don't open like that. No way.
You have a door and there is a lock on it,
but with two keys,
one from the bank
employee, and one from you.
But it's one piece.
So if you cut this one out,
this one is still here.
You have to pull them both
out and then lift them open.
But the first time I did that,
I had blisters this thick
the first time I did it.
I couldn't use my hands.
I underestimated how much
power I had to use to open it.
And I opened a few hundred,
so every time the screwdriver was going,
my palm of my hand, my
hands were this thick.
It really hurt.
It takes at least three,
four minutes to open one.
And the small ones are very tough.
And the ones who were on top,
because I can't put any pressure --
if they were on this
height, I can open it.
But if they were this height,
I couldn't, you know, put
any strength on it or power.
So, a good tip, if you have
a safety deposit in a bank,
make sure it's small and it's on top.
But what do you find in it?
Oky: Everything.
Arthur: Diamonds, gold?
Everything, everything.
You'll find diamonds, gold, pearls,
but you'll also find very heavy pictures
and stuff like that,
that you can really --
I'm not into that, but
what's it called? Extortion?
You could extort.
Really, we see pictures --
or you see people who have a completely,
they have a double life.
I took a bag. And at that time,
I'm talking about 25 years ago --
it had only videotapes.
And at that time,
a videotape recorded with a little screen.
So if you opened it, you could see it.
It's like a laptop.
I think he was watching adult
movies in the safe, you know?
What? Why is it in the safe? [laughs]
Most of the time, they're
in envelopes, small ones.
It looks good in the movie,
but I never found them like that.
I found a lot of diamonds.
Official, in books, you know?
What they are, with the
certificate next to it.
I found books with six diamonds each in it
from, let's say, half a karat to 1, 1 1/2,
2, 2 1/2, 3.
And I found six of these books
that were worth 1.5 million
Swiss francs at the time.
Man, I love colored stones.
Some diamonds with some special color
are very expensive.
But most of the time,
especially the yellow ones
are just off-color diamonds.
You know, they're not worth that much.
Most of the time they're cheaper,
unless they are flawless.
Most of these gangs, they know people
who can sell this stuff. You know?
They can say, "This is good. This is not."
And they will sell it.
If they make you do a job like this
and they know you don't
know nothing about value,
you get screwed, of course.
Arthur: They rip you off.
Oky: That's the diamond business, anyway.
That's it. [laughs]
That's ridiculous. I
don't want to rate it.
No.
It doesn't get a rate.
This is a clip
about one of the most famous
heists ever, in England.
In 2015, a bunch of senior guys
decided to rob a safety-deposit store
somewhere in Hatton Garden, in London.
They got away with diamonds and gold
worth hundreds of millions.
Finally, they got caught,
but still a big part of the loot is gone.
Kenny: Are you there?
Can you hear me?
XXX: Yeah, we can hear you.
There's someone at the front door.
In this scene, the alarm goes off
and the guard doesn't take action.
This does happen.
Just a few months ago,
I was involved in cracking
one of the biggest art
heists ever in Europe.
In 2012,
a guy entered the
National Gallery in Athens
and stole a Picasso.
He set off the alarm on
purpose more than 100 times.
So every time, the guard came looking,
watching for an intruder,
but he was standing behind the curtains.
So after a while, the guy thought,
"There is some technical failure."
So he stopped showing up.
And at that moment,
the guy had a few minutes
to steal the Picasso.
And don't forget, 95%,
in the Netherlands,
of the alarms are fake.
Yeah, when an alarm goes
off, in so many cases,
it's fake because there
is a bird or a curtain.
Oh!
[horn honks]
Jesus.
I don't like lookout.
Because if you have a lookout,
if you're inside, you're safe.
And the lookout is the one who's hot,
because if he walks around,
people go, "Who is this
guy walking around?"
Can you imagine doing that?
They've been in for,
what? 24 hours or longer.
Just one day.
Arthur: Yeah.
If they were in longer,
oof, it would've been big.
But in this case,
this guy who was on the lookout
even fell asleep, you know?
Yeah. But he's hot.
You know? What are you doing here?
It's common for amateurs.
But the mistake in these robberies
was they were texting each other
with their own phones.
They thought they were smart
because there's no phone tap.
But now everybody knows about this.
"Oh, you never call" and this and that.
You don't do that.
But I would rate this movie a 10,
because it shows how it went.
This is one of the biggest heists ever.
[gags]
It looks like it's worth maybe
$30, $40 million or something.
Breathe. Breathe.
[vomiting]
I don't want to take it from the person.
I can see something that
the person is wearing
and then figure out where he lives,
but not ever touch anybody.
But most of these chains
don't even have a lock to
open or close, you know?
And if they have, they have
maybe a triple security,
it doesn't go off in "click," one.
It has to "one, two,
three," and then comes off.
Most of these chains,
they go over your head,
if they're with these kinds of stones.
Why do you need a lock
to open or close it?
I think this one is very heavy.
It's possible to do this.
You know, you have pickpocket
people who can do this.
They take your watch off.
You don't even notice the chain.
Excuse me, we need to go --
Nein! Damentoilette.
The private security, they will go in.
Nobody will stop them,
because they'll have to
be with their subjects.
She can't go out of sight.
It's impossible that somebody
will stop these two guys.
In the Netherlands, it's not allowed
to have private guards with guns,
but outside the Netherlands it's allowed.
Most of these security are ex-military.
So they know a lot about
them, what they did before.
If they're disciplined,
if they can keep them out,
shut what they see or notice.
Yeah. I don't even know
why it's that coordinated
with all kids of people, you know,
put the chain into a soup,
and then it goes to a kitchen, and --
if you have the chain, you run out.
Don't know how you have to get out.
Somebody gets arrested,
they don't find the stuff on him or her,
they already passed it along.
Otherwise you're a suspect.
Then you have to give it to somebody else.
I've been to Monaco to check
these kinds of necklaces.
And it was possible.
But I didn't know that half
the city of Monaco are cops.
I didn't know it's the most
secure place in the world.
It's true.
Two cops on every person
or something like that.
You won't make it.
I would say a 5.
I give it a 4.
OK, here's the copy.
It's not hard to make a knockoff.
You know, with pearls.
With diamonds, it's a different thing.
But with pearls, it's very easy.
Auctioneer: Oh, I have
a 33 million euro bid
from the gentlemen over there, perhaps.
And I don't care if he
has an internet site
and he has a lot of money or whatever.
All the auction houses,
somebody has to authorize who you are.
Not a lot of people
know this, but in 1911,
the "Mona Lisa" was
stolen from the Louvre.
We have quite a few similarities.
I mean, he robbed the Louvre
and I robbed the Van Gogh, so.
Only this is fictional, really.
You know, I didn't watch
the "Lupin" series yet
because why should I, you know?
The real Lupin is sitting next to me.
He can tell me the real story.
And he had to figure it out
to become the person
who cleans everything,
and, you know, it's too much.
It's unrealistic.
All's all, 4.
It's spectacular seeing this,
but of course it doesn't happen this way.
Oky: I never did this.
Arthur: No.
He went down the roof,
and normally in a museum,
the alarm goes off from the roof.
In real life, you wouldn't
do that, because the,
I don't know what it
is, grease or something,
if you go over the ground and
it's gotten on your clothes,
that grease will go everywhere.
It will go in your getaway car,
it'll go in your house, everywhere.
That's why you wouldn't do that.
He needs it just to go over the ground.
I mean, why don't crawl? You know?
Why just a laser on the ground?
Why not the sensor takes the whole room?
You know, this is funny,
but normally you go on your stomach
and you crawl forward.
I did that.
Most of the time they
are in a square case,
and it's inside.
It's not that you can lift something up
and that the bottom stays there.
He grabs the stone with
some sort of gadget.
I can understand he has
to work from the ground
because some sort of
laser or detector, but.
There is nothing harder
than a diamond, you know?
OK, if you take a sledgehammer,
you will break it,
but if you drop this
diamond, that's no problem.
You know, it's fairly hard,
and you cannot scratch it, so don't worry.
The Pink Panthers, they don't leave clues,
but what they did, for example,
they stole "The Scream" by
Munch, like, 20 years ago,
and a painting worth 150 million [pounds].
So they left a note with
a smiley, and they said,
"Thank you for the bad security."
But it's fairly stupid when you do this,
because you have cops
that, when you do that,
they take it personal, and
they will be after you forever.
When you think it's over,
there's still one going,
"Oh, you wrote that letter, right? Wait."
They don't like it.
Arthur: If you tease them,
Oky: Don't do that.
they're going to take it personal.
Normally a professional
won't take these diamonds.
No, that's the thing. You
have to cut these diamonds.
You know, they are known,
so you have to find
someone who can cut them
before you can sell
them on the black market
or on the legal market.
But when you steal diamonds from a museum,
old diamonds,
especially when they are
in some kind of jewelry,
they are not really important diamonds.
So you can't hardly cut them.
So when people steal old diamonds,
they probably didn't
do their homework well.
[alarm ringing]
It would be better if you
would have shown in this clip
Inspector Clouseau, the clumsy inspector
who is going to have to solve this case,
because, you know, when I tracked down
a piece of stolen art
of Picasso or whatever,
they called me "the Indiana
Jones of art" in the media.
But in reality, I'm more
like Clouseau, you know?
Like this inspector, I
follow the wrong suspects.
They feed me with false leads.
When I disguise myself,
I look more ridiculous
than Inspector Clouseau
when he was disguised as a pirate
with an inflatable parrot on his shoulder.
But we do have one thing in common,
and that's that we never give up,
and nobody takes him serious,
but in the end he cracks the case.
I would rate this movie a 10.
4, 5. You know, I mean,
it's too Hollywood.
There you go!
They got it right in this movie.
Because normally in
these Hollywood movies,
they go through the door,
but nobody goes through the door.
It's the most protected path.
This robbery has something to
do with a case that I solved.
That was the ring of Oscar Wilde.
It was stolen in 2002
in Oxford University.
The thief got caught, but he told police
that he had melted the ring down.
Nobody knew that he had
sold the ring to somebody.
And this guy had stored this same ring
in one of these safety
deposits in Hatton Garden.
What I'm doing is profiling.
You know, I'm thinking,
"What would I have done?"
When they showed footage of the burglary,
one of the thieves had rainbow socks on.
Rainbow socks.
And I said, "You check that heist."
Because if it was young guys,
they would destroy the ring
or they would sell it or throw it away.
But only older men have the respect
for the real value of this ring.
So it got stolen again in 2015.
Of course, this guy couldn't
go to the police and say,
"Look, they have stolen
my Oscar Wilde ring,"
because it was stolen before.
I heard rumors on the market
that a certain ring had
appeared on the market
appearing to be Oscar Wilde's ring.
So Oky came to my home,
and he said he did this heist,
and in many of these safes,
he found stolen art, you
know, stolen jewelry.
So he gave me the leads,
and then I approached these
guys, these senior guys,
and, finally, I tracked the ring back.
They had sold it because they didn't know
it was the ring of Oscar Wilde.
They sold it to a jewelry shop,
which sold it to some guy.
So it shows that stolen jewels
do appear on the black market.
In this case, even on the legal market.
And the recovery rates for
art theft are very small.
I think that around
7% or 8% is being recovered.
The rest disappears forever.
Basil: I'm just checking
for wear on the pads.
You can work out the code by
identifying the most worn ones.
I opened doors like that. It's true.
But then you have to know the combination,
because if you have four times four,
I don't know how many
combinations you have. Hundreds.
There are different
ways to open this door.
You don't need a key.
He has a piece of paper,
I guess. Uncut key.
He pulls it in, and when he flips it,
he will see the guts of
the mechanism inside.
And then cuts it off.
And then it will turn.
Let's give it a 10.
A 10, because it really happened.
And it's really what they do. It's real.
This is the famous, the nitrogen.
Very dangerous.
If it falls like that on your finger,
you can break it off.
I know a few very serious burglars.
They never used this.
Joey: Hey, Nick.
Nick: Joey, talk to me.
Tell me what you got.
It's not here.
But the distraction thing
is an interesting one.
Somebody is threatening
to kill themselves.
So everybody's distracted.
And this does happen.
The most famous gang of
art thieves in the world
are the Pink Panthers.
They are named after the Hollywood film.
They come from Yugoslavia,
and this gang has both
male and female members.
And they do use these tricks.
In 2004 in the Louvre, there
was an antiquities fair,
and there was a diamond worth $60 million.
It was on display. Bright
lights, security guards.
But then the wife of the
French minister arrived,
so everybody looked for
a second the other way.
And when they looked back,
the diamond was gone.
In another case, they painted a bench
in front of a jewelry shop in Miami
that they were about to hit
because they didn't want
anybody to sit there
and become a witness on what they do.
They used pretty women to distract guards
and all stuff like that.
So this does happen.
If you got a wrong mechanism inside,
the whole door locks.
You don't open it.
You won't open it again, you know?
Yeah. Also a 4 or a 3.
I mean, you get caught
if you do it like that.
Thank you for watching.
If you want to see more,
click the video above.